whoa
megan the stallion and miles teller
[Music]
this episode of ati is brought to you by
curve stick around for all the details
on the curved car but for right now
let's get into these questions i'm just
bring now it's like mike stud
what's up i'm brie i'm grace and we're
gonna be answering the internet when
you're drunk is it better to get laid or
have the ideal drunk meal it's like
drunk meal yeah because then you don't
have to wake up and like totally regret
i'd regretted a couple drunk meals
though
not as hard as some drunken lace
yeah i'm talking out
ideal drunk meal well for me it's just
taco bell
yeah taco bell is good when you wake up
and you're [ __ ] [ __ ] your brains out
there's nothing but then you could wake
up with gonorrhea too
would you rather your girlfriend oh
sorry would you rather your boyfriend be
able to read your thoughts during sex or
all the time except during sex oh [ __ ]
i'm never thinking anything good
i'd rather be able to read during sex
have be able to read me during sex
yeah i mean
i think i'd rather it's sex
because i would well then i'd just be in
my head all the time don't think
anything bad don't think anything bad
but then you'd have to be paranoid for
all the time just like think good things
think good things i think like when i'm
having sex is like the only time i
really like my boyfriend
so i'd go out with sex
we had a funny thought one time it was
um
do you ever think that people can read
your mind so you start saying something
in your head and we say the same thing
in our head and we do that yeah i mean
so we
both think that people can read our
minds sometimes and then we both say
i'm a banana banana
i'm a banana she says banana banana and
we came to this conclusion like we
didn't even know this boy
yes banana banana i was like are you
[ __ ] with me right now i'm like are
you [ __ ] with me i'm like i know this
is like a crazy thought and like i'm
probably [ __ ] with me but like i
think i'm a banana but yeah i just think
bananas bananas bananas bananas
yeah it's like holy moly that's crazy
would you rather live in new york or la
but you can never visit the other one
again
oh [ __ ] new york new york easily i mean
la is much too
boring yeah nobody does anything in l.a
they only go on fridays and saturdays
like yeah well it's like rehab maybe we
should go to l.a there's rehabs in new
york
yeah we go in new york you get arrested
and free sorry i'm bad at reading you
get arrested and for your one call you
can only call another barstool employee
who is it can't be each other oh who's
going to pick up who's not going to give
you a hard time about it who's reliable
who's sober and reliable
[Laughter]
i can't call you what the [ __ ] you
actually probably wouldn't answer will
you be in jail with me
i would always answer big cat
what do you see in town that week
[Laughter]
i've actually never talked to big cats
like this
who the [ __ ] would i call realistically
and and i have to call a barstool
employee that everybody knows i'm gonna
probably go kelly she's like an older
sister kelly giggs she would she's home
oh i'm calling kate
okay i'm calling kate you're going to
make her do that yeah she would in a
heartbeat and she'd bring cash
she'd bring cash yeah i'm going to cash
the bell you owed her casual kid both
would you rather have sex with someone
who only washed between their knees and
their belly button or someone who only
washes from the knees
down and belly button up genitals clean
yeah okay so okay
well i mean if i'm diving into the bits
and pieces where i want the bits and
pieces cleaned right
i think i think you need that junk claim
yeah right yeah
but he'll be
you know his pits will be gross and
stinky
you get i mean your hair is why you have
some stinkies
yeah
again talking out of my ass
i
[Laughter]
dirty balls it is yeah you don't want
your dirty ass dirty ass dirty dirty
jingle bells [ __ ] oh
okay
if barstool had a beauty pageant what
would your talent be no one ever has an
answer to this which is amazing a
company of the talents of the town yeah
literally
live podcasting
i can do like that i can do
this
yeah
i could do this
pretty cool she's been dying to do this
for so
the first one with the actual talent
thank you
always drunk
or never be able to drink again
like a better person
you gotta go to business meetings you
gotta go funerals way halfway there
i don't know where you think i am in
life right now
all right if there was stats available
for every aspect of your life what one
stat would you want to see oh how many
didn't we talk about
did we talk about that we did how many
drinks ever consumed yes oh yes that how
many what how many alcoholic beverages
have i ever assumed no you're not gonna
feel good about it but how many people
have ever loved you ever yeah i had it
yeah that is a dangerous one that that
was what i was gonna say yeah because i
could either be like awesome or like
[ __ ] my fear is like it's four and
you're like
how i didn't even think family oh yeah
how much money would it take for you to
go on a date with andrew tate
zero
you want to go on a date with him
honestly i want i would want to go on a
date with him for free and just see if
he's actually crazy yeah i don't want to
go on a date with him i'd like to get in
the room with him but i don't want to go
on a date what does that mean
a legitimate date probably like like 20
grand
just to sit down like and he's paying
like a nice mail get to talk to them
and then i can talk about him on my
podcast i want a waterborne
okay if you were gay for a day who would
you be want to bang i could talk
so who would it be i don't know
who do you have the biggest bad crush on
i don't
see this is where it gets to be not a
joke anymore
i'm gonna obviously megan fox see i'm
gonna say megan fox but it's like too
easy miley cyrus
my size
wait does the other one have to be gay
too
[Laughter]
rather date a guy who [ __ ] a thousand
girls or one animal thousand girls
thousand girls
you kidding
a guy that's [ __ ] like a dog nobody
knows except for you
so it's not like but i know yeah and i'm
just dating the animal [ __ ] but yeah
you do know oh no god no good on the
animal [ __ ] that's
yeah nice andrew tate i'd rather [ __ ]
understand that's crazy and he's an
animal
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out oh what sorry guys
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out for i'm
sorry what's the worst thing you've
gotten thrown out of a bar for this is
where it's triggered like harrison i've
stole a bunch of silverware oh yeah
in college you were there
we stole a bunch yup stole it all then i
left my bag there with my fake id in it
they found all the [ __ ] forks and
knives they're like you're banned from
here you're a [ __ ] loser and that was
humiliating
or are you doing it for fun are you like
i need silverware uh it was nowhere in
the college dorm days i was needed
silverware yeah
i stole it
um i didn't get into the bar but uh
while we were waiting to get in i had
somebody's real id
to use as a fake id and she had like a
stye
in the picture
so i'm standing in line like digging my
skin like trying to have that same style
yeah and i got it and he's like you
didn't have to do all that like you
don't even look like her
i was like all right then you have a
good night guys
it's also like she took a picture that
day yeah
self-harm for no reason
she was also a hair yeah she wasn't a
heroin addict
who would you rather [ __ ] logan or jake
paul
jake paul okay i hate logan paul i
could put it past me yeah
i could put the hate past
would you rather everyone in your
boyfriend's office want to [ __ ] him or
nobody want to [ __ ] him
everybody everyone wants to [ __ ] him
because at the end of the day he's
coming on me
yeah yeah
you don't want a boyfriend that
everyone's like
the girl in the office
people in the office have sex with each
other oh no my boyfriend would
definitely cheat on me
i probably would have to go the ladder
who from game of thrones would you bring
on your sleep on your dead tour you have
three slots i would bring jon snow
because i [ __ ] him over and over again
um
a tiny fella
that's fine okay um i love my little
tiny fellas jon snow
jon snow tyrion
and then would i want to bring kalisi
getting a little gay tonight probably
khaleesi
yeah yeah if you could see a sex tape
with any two movie characters who would
it be miles teller i was gonna say we
were watching a miles teller movie the
other day and they weren't showing
enough of the sex scene and we would
like show us more of the sex scene but
who do we want to see him [ __ ] i go
bleak lively but they don't really match
very well jennifer anderson
no
i don't want to say that together
yeah
she just stepped her stepson
it's jennifer aniston maybe meg
megan the stallion whoa whoa
megan the stallion and miles teller sure
have you seen her ass on instagram yeah
that's a smoothie ass shots what she in
a movie oh she has to be a character
miles and jennifer lawrence oh that's a
good one who would be your three dream
people to drink with seth rogen
no that's smoking can they relapse
what shall blushy
okay i was thinking people that went
sober that used to be fun drinking like
maybe like lindsay lohan back in the day
oh chris farley lucy
farley and who's the girlfriend lindsay
lohan lindsay lohan i only have lindsay
lohan
we'll do the trio lohan brittany paris
oh but i don't want a [ __ ] drink with
britney spears
absolutely not maybe paris and
i was going to say kim but no maybe
chloe when once you got arrested chloe
was fun
yeah that's when she was close money
yeah that's best before she would take
tristan's [ __ ]
chloe lindsay anders
thanks for watching answer the internet
one question i've always had is why
can't we consolidate all of our cards
into one card and the answer is here
it's the curve card put your debit card
on there put your credit card on there
decide where you want to put the money
you can still get all the points and
benefits from those cards as well as
points on curve right now sign up at
curve.com barstool and with your first
transaction you can get twenty dollars
of curved cash today that's curve dot
com slash barstool would you rather give
up the hungover breakfast sandwich or
the drunk pizza i'd rather give up the
sandwich hung over i don't even eat one
hungover yeah yeah i'm just sick it's 15
liquids are both yeah a soda a chocolate
milk a gatorade uh a colada and then a
mimosa and like a coffee if you have to
go to work i didn't realize like i've
never just attacked a hangar with water
water
yeah i don't know
[Laughter]
no tits or no drip
no tits
i was no tits for a while
i think the tits is the only thing i
have going for me and i don't really
drip so hard
you you would go back to notes
go back to no tips for sorry yeah sure
no drip can't live no no drip imagine
just like imagine soda to work like
[Applause]
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel
set reminders with a little bell comment
who you want to see do it and watch all
the other answer the internets i don't
know where anything is so i'm kind of
just moving my hands around but do all
that [ __ ] subscribe comment reminder
watch others you're welcome don't know
why but you're welcome